I have never known a dead man
who gets himself in more (bleep)
than Richard Nixon, you guys.
I just want to say that
for the record.
Uh, check out the latest
on Tricky McDick.
NEWSWOMAN: Forbes reports on a
remark by a former Nixon aide
hinting that the War on Drugs
had a hidden purpose--
that President Nixon saw
the drug crackdown
as a way to arrest blacks
and anti-war protestors.
Ehrlichman also claimed
that the White House knew
they were lying about drugs.
-(audience oohing)
-Now... I know, I know.
This may sound shocking
to a lot of people out there,
but to most black people,
this just confirms
what they
already suspected, okay?
Now, to give
his thoughts on this,
and the black perspective,
let's go out to Mike Yard
for an edition
of No (bleep) News.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering)
Okay, uh, Mike...
Mike, your thoughts
on the Nixon aide's admission
that the War on Drugs
was based on lies
and really about
oppressing black people.
Yeah, no (bleep).
WILMORE:
Okay.
Sounds about right.
Mike Yard with the No (bleep)
News, everybody. Thanks, Mike!
(cheering, applause)
That was great.
It's my favorite news...
It's where I get
all my news, you guys.
(laughter)
That's the shortest
news program ever.
Now, the Nixon aide in question
is the late John Ehrlichman,
who admitted that the
War on Drugs was created in 1971
to silence Nixon's
greatest opposition groups.
Ehrlichman said-- and I quote...
I know.
Now, look, guys,
I just got to say,
I have to formally apologize
to any conspiracy brother
who has ever put forth
a conspiracy that I dismissed.
-(laughter) -Including
the moon landing, at this point.
Yeah, which I-I just assume
was produced by Paramount.
You're right, brother,
you're right.
Sorry, Buzz, that was
some good acting, okay?
But look, guys, this (bleep)
is even worse than I imagined,
and it could explain
why black people,
despite representing only 12%
of our nation's drug users
make up 59%
of Americans
currently in prison
for drug-related offenses.
Well, that's before Obama
lets all the brothers
out of his prison
on his last day!
(cheering, applause)
Payback's a bitch!
(laughter)
Sorry. I had a black attack.
I apologize.
But seriously, I mean, no, guys,
if the man was able to pull off
such an elaborate conspiracy
just to keep the brother down,
then that must mean...
O.J. really didn't do it.
-♪ ♪
-(laughter)
Okay.
(quietly):
No. Hmm.
No, seriously, though,
the Nixon White House
sickens me, okay?
I mean, I just find
this behavior just so...
so... (stammers)
MORTON:
Detestable.
The word you're seeking
is "detestable."
-(cheering, applause)
-WILMORE: Exactly. Hey!
It's Joe Morton, everybody!
Joe Morton!
Oh, my God!
(cheering, applause continue)
How's it going, Joe?
He plays, uh,
Rowan Pope on Scandal,
of course.
Now, no one understands
detestable government acts
better than Papa Pope, right?
Okay, okay, so, what would
he say about this situation?
Well, he would address
the people
who needed proof
that the War on Drugs
was a war
on black people directly.
Uh... may I?
Oh, oh, yes, by all means.
-You know...
-Well... thank you, Larry.
Oh, yeah.
Now, I'd like to address...
America.
You ignored what happened,
and you're ignoring
what's happening.
This, dear sweet America,
is what happened.
Nixon chose to keep black folks
under control
by arresting their leaders,
raiding their homes,
and vilifying them
night after night
on the evening news.
But you chose
to watch reality TV,
eat fast food,
screw your spouses, or your
battery-operated products...
-(laughter) -and only think
about the freedoms
that your fellow Americans
did not have
when it was convenient for you.
-(woman whoops)
-AUDIENCE MEMBERS: Yeah! Yeah!
If I were you, America,
I would be afraid...
very afraid.
You are on the brink
of giving your country away
to a man whose only interests
are money and TV ratings.
Trump. He, like Nixon, promises
to "make America great again."
That's code
for profiling Muslims,
raiding their homes
and vilifying them
night after night
on the evening news.
(cheering, applause)
Trump will gut you
and leave you bleeding
out of your wherevers.
That's the Trump presidency
versus America.
Maya Angelou once said, "When
someone shows you who they are,
believe them the first time."
(cheering, applause)
We didn't believe it
when it was Nixon,
but today
I'm telling you, America,
believe it and stay woke.
The American people need to get
rid of this tiny-figured,
micro-digited,
rotting papaya-faced,
hate-geyser vulgarian brat,
come hell or high water.
(cheering, applause)
Because, to be clear,
if Trump gets elected,
it's the American people
who are the hell
and the high water.